hi guys
so today's tutorial is on aws cloudfront
before starting this tutorial
make sure that you like our channel and
also subscribe
our channel the link you can find it
just below at the right side of this
video let's look into what we have today
in the cloud front so what's in it for
you
we would be covering up the concept of
what is aws
what was earlier uh before aws
cloudfront
after aws cloudfront what were the
services that were introduced how it
benefited
what do we mean by aws cloudfront
benefits of
the using aws cloudfront and how aws
cloudfront actually is known as a
content delivery service
the name of the companies that are using
aws cloudfront
and we would be covering up one live
demo
now aws is the amazon web services it's
a cloud service provider
that basically offers a multiple
services variety of services
such as compute power database storage
networking and other resources so that
you can
create your solutions on the cloud and
help the business grow
now with aws you only pay for whatever
the services you use so for example if
you are using a service for a couple of
hours then you pay for only that many
hours
that you have used that service
before aws cloud front so there is an
example that we are going to talk and
that is
you must be aware of an application
called spotify
so when you used to access spotify and
when you click on it it kept on loading
and
at the end you used to get the error and
the error was that the connection failed
and why you received that error because
of
a latency issue probably a network error
right so how you can solve these kind of
a latency issues
and that is also going to these kind of
an issues are also going to impact the
performance of an application so with
the introduction of aws cloud from this
problem
of loading the application got resolved
so
after aws cloudfront with the help of
adobe slot front spotify gives
the facility of updating new features
access to million
songs that you can access instantly
so with the use of aws cloud front or
the latency issues were solved
and successfully you can basically
access your
application now what we mean by aws
cloudfront
so aws cloudfront is a globally
distributed network
that is offered by aws amazon web
services
which securely delivers content to the
end users
across any geography with a higher
transfer speed
and an improve or a low latency now what
are the benefits of aws cloudfront
there are multiple benefits one is the
cost effective
so it helps you to do the cost
optimization when you use the
cloud front it is time saving
so it is implemented easily
and also lot of issues with respect to
accessing the application
with respect to latency and all can be
resolved
content privacy so the content is
placed to the end users and also
to the cloudfront servers in a
secured manner in a secured way it is
highly programmable
and you can make the changes amend the
changes on the fly
and you can target any location any
geography across the globe
along with that it helps you to get the
content
deliver quickly now how aws cloudfront
delivers the content
let's look into the architecture so
this is a flow and the flow is with
respect to how the user is going to get
a content
from the cloud front now the client
first access a website by typing a url
on the browser
and in the step one it acts tries to
access the application
then the client requests when the
website is open the client request
for an object to download such as for
example a particular file
now at that time the dns
routes user request to download that
file to aws cloudfront
the aws cloud front connects to the
nearest
edge locations edge locations are
basically the servers
where it caches the files documents and
the web
codes aws cloudfront connects to its
nearest edge location
in order to serve the user the request
at edge location aws crowdfund looks for
its requested cache file
once the file is found let's say if the
file is available in the cache of an
edge location
aws cloudfront then sends the file to
the
user otherwise if the file is not found
in the cache
memory of an edge location aws
cloudfront
compares the requirement with the
specification and share it with a
respected server that means a web server
or a server where the file is actually
available
the server the web server responds to
the edge location by sending
the file back to the cloud front edge
location
and then as soon as the aws cloud front
receives the file
it shares with the client also adds the
file to the cache of an
edge location for a future reference
this is how the
flow of a cloud front is now the name of
the companies that are using the aws
cloud front
so one of them is jio7 app which is
which is a very popular app so it uses
amazon cloudfront to deliver
15 petabytes of audio and video to its
subscribers globally
which is a huge data sky news
it uses the service in order to unify
the content for faster distribution to
scrub subscribers
or the discovery communications also
uses the cloud front it uses the service
for delivering api
static asset and also the dynamic
content
and then the tv one eu streaming europe
is basically also uses the cloudfront
service
that helps in improving latency and
performance that results in fastest
delivery of content now let's look into
the demo how to use cloudfront to serve
private s3 bucket as a website
now i'm going to run a cloudfront
distribution demo
on the aws console and
we basically try to deliver the content
from a private s3 bucket
and then map that with the domain name
using the root 53 service
so what we need for this demo we will
need
a domain url we would need a route 53
service
we would need cloud front uh we have to
create a cloudfront distribution
and that will be linked with our s3
bucket the private s3 bucket
right and in the s3 bucket we would have
one html file the index.html file
so let's move into aws console
so right now i have opened up the
cloudfront distribution
and here you can see that couple of
distributions have already been created
so what i'm going to do i'm going to
create a distribution
now there are two types of delivery
method for your content
one is the web distribution and the
other one is
rtmp rtmp stands for real time
audio or video distribution it's
basically
used for distribution of a media content
or a media file which are available in
the s3 bucket
here we are going to select a web
distribution
because primarily we will be using files
which uses
protocols http or the https
so you have to click on get started and
in the origin domain name you have to
specify
the bucket where your code is available
so i have a bucket already created
here you can see and what you need to do
is you have to create a bucket
with the url name or the domain name
which you would be mapping with the
route 53 service so this is a bucket
that has already been created let me
show you in a new tab
so here you have to go to the storage
under the storage
you have to select the s3 bucket let's
open the link in the new tab and let's
look into
how we can create the s3 buckets
now here are a couple of buckets already
created i have created one bucket with
the domain name that i'm
going to use and map it with the route
53 service
so that is basically mapped to a region
which is in
ohio and if you open up this bucket
here you will find an html web page the
index.html has been
already added right so similarly you
have to
create a bucket with a domain and an
index.html page
needs to be uploaded there now again
we'll go to the cloud front we will try
to create a distribution
just have to click on create
distribution
select a web delivery method select an
origin domain
which is sunshinelearning.in
and origin path you don't have to
specify origin id
is this one so basically when you define
an origin domain name
automatically the origin id appears you
can customize this origin id as per your
requirement also so rest of the things
primarily we keep it as a default
settings only
until and unless if we require some
customized settings to be done
so let's say if you have to change the
cache behavior settings you can do that
otherwise we'll keep it as default
now in the distribution setting you can
either select
use all edge locations for the best
performance so what does aws
basically do here it uses all the edge
locations
which are associated with aws across the
globe
otherwise you can specify based on the
regions also
right apart from that if you want to
enable firewalls or the access control
list you can specify here
and then what you need to do is
in the default root object here you have
to specify
your index.html page which is
in the s3 bucket the distribution state
has to be enabled
and if you want to use ipv6 as well you
need to enable it
click on create distribution
now you you can see here a distribution
has been created
it's in progress and it is enabled
and it takes around 15 to 20 minutes to
get that distribution
completed the reason is that the web
codes the web pages will be
distributed across all the edge
locations across the globe so hence it
takes time
to get that done right now let's move on
to
route 53 service and let's create the
hosted zones
so we'll type root 53 here scalable dns
and domain name registration
and what we are going to do here is we
are going to map
our url the domains
pointed to the name servers that will be
provided by the route 53 so we have to
create a hosted zone
let's wait for it so
now the route 53 dashboard is open and
you can see one hosted zone is already
created so just click on the hosted
zones
and in order to point the traffic from
the external domains
towards the aws you have to first point
the domains traffic
to the hosted zone in the route53
so i'll click on create hosted zone but
before that i will
first delete the existing one and then
i'll
create another record another hosted
zone
right put your domain name
let's say i put us sunshine learning dot
in
and it is acting as a public hosted zone
rest of the things will be default
click on create hosted zone
now it gives you four name servers and
these four name servers has to be
updated
in the domain so you have to update
these name servers in a platform from
where you have purchased the
domain right so this is half of the work
done
then what you need to do is you have to
go and create
a records now in the records you can
select a routing policy so right now
what we are targeting
we are targeting basically that the
traffic from the domain should be
pointed directly towards the cloudfront
distribution
hence we are going with a simple routing
right now
click on next here you have to
specify the record sets so we are going
to create the records
uh just click on default simple record
put here as world wide web
and you have to select an end point so
end point we are selecting for the
cloudfront distribution so we have to
specify
alias for the cloudfront distribution
now here we are going to put the
cloudfront distribution url
and then we are going to define the
simple report set
so what we need is we need a cloudfront
distribution url
which you can find it from the
cloudfront service itself
and you can find the domain name here
itself
you just have to copy that
and then paste it here
in the distribution and then
just click on define simple records
again click on create records
and here you can see the record set has
been updated
now this domain is basically
pointed towards these name servers which
are further pointed
towards the cloud front distribution
right
now the only thing which is left is that
within the domain from wherever you have
purchased the domain
you should update these phone name
servers and
then you can see the live traffic coming
on this domain
will have an output from the cloudfront
distribution
that's it from us guys thanks for
watching our video
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here